à moscou passée sanitaire obligatoire
pour aller au restaurant une décision
municipale aujourd'hui pour tenter de
mettre un coup d'arrêt à la flambée des
99 dans la capitale russe la
correspondance entre en russie à danton
éclairant antoine de nouvelles mesures
ont donc été décidée à moscou et quelles
sont elles oui bien les autorités sont
passés à la vitesse supérieure dans
l'adoption de mesures contraignantes
afin de tenter de mettre un coup de
frein dans dans la flambée de cette
pandémie sur le territoire us après
avoir décrété la vaccination obligatoire
à destination des employés du secteur
tertiaire
il faudra désormais montrer patte
blanche à l'entrée des restaurants
écouter à partir du 28 juin 2021
seuls ceux qui sont protégés contre le
coc u19 pourront fréquenter les
restaurants ceux qui se sont fait
vacciner ceux qui ont été infectés par
le cos vie 19 au cours des six derniers
mois
ceux qui ont un pcr négatif de -2 3
jours la décision adoptée par les
autorités de moscou rappelle les mesures
prises en israël au moment du des
confirmands au mois au printemps dernier
et pour le porte-parole du kremlin ci
est inéluctable il y aura de plus en
plus de différence de traitement entre
les personnes immunisées et les autres
écoutez le comportement du virus est si
inhabituelle que d'une manière ou d'une
autre
ceux qui ne sont pas vaccinés et ceux
qui n'ont pas d'anticorps
c'est à dire ceux qui n'ont pas
d'immunité ces personnes se retrouveront
d'une manière ou d'une autre dans une
position moins avantageuses que celles
qui ont une immunité soit parce qu'elles
ont eu cette maladie soit parce qu'elles
ont été vaccinées c'est la réalité dans
laquelle nous vivons et nous devrons
vivre avec cette réalité dans un avenir
prévisible
mais c'est une autre histoire que parce
que vous voyez la vaccination n'est pas
une fin en soi c'est l'immunisation qui
est une fin en soi
il faut dire que les chiffres sont
particulièrement affolant la maire
adjointe de moscou a fait savoir cet
après midi que le nombre de cas
identifiés avaient bondi de 100% en
l'espace de seulement trois semaines
d'où les décisions radicales prises ces
derniers jours merci antoine claireaux
pour toutes ces précisions en direct de
moscou dont